hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
sat with my very good friend
alex there cunningham what's happening
brother hey i'm good how are you how are
you so this is kind of like we don't
normally do videos together and
obviously
russell and ricky anyone but me i know
we don't we
i don't know why but we we had our
winners on the wednesdays um you've just
come around the house but
other than that yeah we don't jump on
video that often we're too busy we're
too busy we're too busy but listen folks
alistair has just written
a book and the book isn't about property
it's about being a speaker
here's something you don't know about
alistair alice there started off
in property made a decent amount of
money on property you probably read his
book you've seen him on winners
wednesday
and then what happened i was there um a
couple of things like i i got
i became financially free in property
and i started making all this money and
started doing all these deals
and it became really good and then we
went out to africa
about three years ago today it's
actually about three years ago i saw
some
memories come back on facebook and
during that trip
you obviously bust your leg i still got
this you still pull the scars i'll just
look at that
yeah um but when we were out there we
were supposed to be doing
a business workshop and back then i i
wasn't doing that much speaking i was
doing a little
bit but not that much i think it was
mainly
just come on do two minutes tell people
what you've just done but it wasn't
doing much speaking and
we were there we've got a situation
where you've got your bust leg you ain't
going anywhere
you're wrecked um and but we've got this
business workshop to deliver
and i want to say i was thrown in the
deep end
because i was but i had to step up and
you basically said look the mission goes
on
my pain is temporary their pain is is
long-term
so we need to crack home we need to get
on with it but we've got this business
workshop to do so alastair
you need to get on with it yeah and you
need to make sure that we deliver
whatever we're going to deliver
yeah but i was going to deliver you need
to now deliver and
obviously i was nervous i was like i've
never done this before i've never done
more than sort of two or three minutes
on stage but you know
the best time to grow is when you're at
your comfort zone and when you're facing
the heat and you're in pressure
and with help with help from russell and
a few other people
we stepped up and we delivered that that
seminar too so basically a bit of
context
was as you guys know i run a lot of
training events
i'm a speaker a motivational speaker
also a business property trainer as well
as a developer as well as an investor
so alistair financially free i'm like
dude you need to start doing a bit of
speaking and you need to
so he gives just this workshop with
these you know
where you go and you get when you're
uganda it was with his budding
business entrepreneurs and as a result
of alastair's training and
when he gave his speech and he shared
what he'd done a lot of good came out of
that
great feedback some businesses were set
up as a result a lot of people in the
village of prospect
i think being an educator and a speaker
is really important
and and you kind of got very a lot of
satisfaction from do you know do you
know
when we went out we were there right and
i remember we're in this room this this
conference room in the middle of ginger
uh we had we had about 200 people due to
attend and
um i remember i was sitting there
eagerly waiting for people to turn up
and nobody turned up till about 11
o'clock and then they started
they started filtering in my nerves were
going crazy because i'm like this is not
what i do
i'm a property guy i'm making money in
property i'm not a speaker
um and you know what i went on stage and
i just done it
and then i just done what exactly
exactly what we worked together what you
taught was like what you told me
and by the end of the day we had these
150 200 people in the room
that had little light bulb moments now
we weren't teaching in depth not we were
teaching basic business
um but what really got me that day
was you can impact so many people
like so many people we were just
teaching basic basic business
but out there that to them they didn't
know that they didn't know this basic
how to write businesses
in this country yeah yeah it's hidden in
the schools it's not in the curriculums
we're building schools in uganda saying
we want to partner with the government
education so okay so that's when you
first developed the love
the education of speaking well that
spiraled it so i i come back from that
event we continued the trip we got back
and about a month later i started
getting messages from people that were
at that event
yeah and they were saying of very broken
english but
thank you mr cunningham thank you we we
really got a lot from you and it was
just so nice
that something i'd said and i'd done has
inspired people from a completely
different world to do something with
their life
and then i got thinking well i can do
this with property because
i've done a lot on property and i can
help people teach property so then you
spoke to me about
doing some more advanced training and
helping uh teach people at the property
event so then i got involved with that
and before you know it just boomed and i
i again i never intended to be a speaker
very much accidentally you've taken that
though like to that a whole new level
yeah
you know i mean for me teaching property
is kind of a mission kind of something
that i do
you're out speaking in india yeah you're
getting gigs now to get
booked up to go and speak in las vegas
yeah speaking all over the world you've
spoken in asia you've spoken
about whether it be business leadership
personal development
mindset yeah a big part of your thing is
your mindset was keeping you poor 100
percent
help people get over that so what is it
that you
are teaching besides obviously property
which is what we
teach in our company but what is it one
of the one of the things i truly believe
if you've got something inside of you
that you believe somebody else can
benefit from you need to share that
message
okay so if you if like you say if you
were if you were like if you were fat
and you've lost loads of weight and you
can help people lose weight share that
message
if you were suffering from depression
share that message if you were suffering
if let's say
one of these the students i'm working
with at the minute this guy called dave
smith
suffered he done three tours of
afghanistan massive um
massive amazing guy come back suffering
massively from ptsd
being suicidal numerous times he's come
along and i've worked with him and he's
done some he's done some training with
me
and that gave him the power to then
do like social media to actually speak
on social media about his ptsd
and what happened was one of his friends
from the military
reached out to him on the day that he
done the video so he done a tick tock
video of all
he put a tick tock video out there
saying hi my name's dave and i'm going
to be
talking to you to say basically it's
okay if you're suffering from ptsd i can
help you
one of his mates reached out to him just
before he committed suicide
and his mate was about to take a load of
pills to end his life
but david's video gave him the power and
gave him the belief that it's okay to
ask for help
yeah and that's why i do what i do
because it saves lives and it helps
people get over whatever
whatever [ __ ] story they're telling
themselves why they can't succeed
it just helps them and that's not even
you training no that's you
teaching someone else how to share their
story
and one of the things that has been
really popular as well a lot of my
students have come over to you in
is people because people come to me all
the time and they're like samuel can i
be a trainer like you yeah can i be a
speaker
i'm like i ain't got the time to i have
all the time the energy the inclination
to start teaching people how to be a
speaker or how to be a whereas
you have i have because i i've got my
property income
i've still done all the property stuff
but i can make time because
it's more about my mission yes my
mission is to help people
spread the message of whatever they want
to spread it doesn't matter what that is
your mis your message will be different
to samuel's message to my message
but i understand that you need to get
that message out there in order to
impact and help other people
and that's why i came to you i actually
came to you a couple of months but
probably towards the end of last year
and i said samuel i want to help people
become speakers and leaders and trainers
and you as a leader said what do you
need from me
yeah you said i'm busy what do you need
from me to make this happen
yeah we had a conversation and you said
right i'll support you a hundred percent
but it's on you you've got to make this
happen and that's what i'm doing you're
now running your first
um well not your first but you're
running your first
publicized yeah official speaker
training day yeah which is called
six figure speaker summit what do you
call it six figure speakers on it
because you know what when you share
your passion with such conviction
you get paid an awful lot of money for
this um and you've got the capability to
go and earn a lot of money and the
reason why i call it that
is because i accidentally became a
speaker and then as a result of me
sharing my message
i started getting paid all this money
and it's like you started getting booked
up
all across yeah started getting speed
gigs i
as you know i'm a speaker by the way i
don't
take much money from no you don't you
don't and
you're fine with that now what samuel
does is
he he's so busy in property and he's so
busy
with all these big deals and people are
reaching out to you and you're like
saying
i'm i'm too busy at the minute you you
serve them with the property and you
sell them you serve them and you serve
them
um and then you just do your property
stuff and
um it's just yeah auto take a salary
from training alex then does
right yeah you get you know i'm not
ashamed to admit that
because i deliver very well what i do
yeah
uh and i know my mission and my my my um
my message is helping and serving people
how much do you get paid
to go and deliver a speech well that's
that's covered all right all i'll say is
i'm on six figures
um but listen i i've i've been booked up
before
i know you've got played 25 grand plus
yeah yeah okay fine yeah
no i have um i i've got gigs raised gigs
i've got engagements ranging from a
couple thousand pounds up to
25 yeah and but i've also do a lot for
free as well
and i do do a lot for free because i
want to serve and i want to give back
but there's nothing wrong with getting
paid for what you do so the reason why i
called it the six figure speaker summit
is because you can make a career out of
doing this do you believe
that there's a lot of people maybe
watching this video
that you could teach the skills how to
speak on stage how to feel
confident how to be a leader and they
would be able to potentially make
six figures one thousand percent
and i'll tell you why because i've
worked with people that are already
in in on the way to doing that um david
smith's one of them hillary's more of
them
i take ricky mandel um there's all these
people
that have come through the training that
i've worked with them i've helped them
and they're now getting speaking
engagements they're now doing speaking
it might be that you
are already financially free in property
or business you're making good money
and you want to become a speaker just to
have be a better communicator to become
more active
it will help you in business or it might
be that you want to make
an extra income or whatever being a
speaker so tell me the details of this
event that you've got coming up how long
is it going to last what is it how much
does it cost
okay so it's two days uh you're gonna
you're gonna come along you're gonna
spend two days with me and i'm gonna
show you all the skills that you need to
become
uh a very well paid uh public speaker
and to deliver your message and impact
life and impact change on others
uh now i know you're excited about that
because i get so many people asking me
about this
um it's gonna be held in central london
it's gonna be held on the 31st of july
and the first of august
and you know what two days of my time
and i'm inviting you along as my guest
it's just come along for free i think
there's like a one pound booking charge
but the the tickets are free
and do you know what you need to be
there uh end the month
two days you've got a message share it
with the world
share it with the masters and get it out
there so there we have it if you want to
learn to be a
speaker a public speaker a better
communicator a leader you want to grow
i would say definitely take alistair's
invitation to spend two days with
alastair his own
training program six figure speaker
summit it's going to be amazing
i don't think i'm going to be there
because i actually think i'm running an
event somewhere you're speaking
somewhere else yeah we're not doing
something else
um but don't worry about what i'm doing
get down to that program so we is going
to be a link in the description yeah
we'll stick a link below uh get richer
that is filling up fast low so make sure
you get registered
uh we're limited to about 150 people and
we've already got quite a lot of number
tickets sold so get registered right now
and i'll see you there get registered
see you guys soon i hope this video
helped god bless